law went to save luffy at marineford not
because he's such a nice guy but because
he knew that luffy was a d he was
actually incredibly disappointed when
luffy beat flamingo and his name
trafalgar d water law holds the key to
the shockingly important role that law
still has to play in the story if just
like me you've also always struggled to
fully understand lost thoughts and
objectives and why the hell he's
actually still around even after taking
down his sworn enemy today i will
unravel everything you ever wanted to
know about his character for you
okay
the thing that intrigued me the most
about trafalgar law when he was first
introduced early on in the story was how
hard it was to read his thoughts and
actions on sabah odi we meet him as this
pretty messed up guy in hippie clothes
that has fun tormenting his enemies
always with a smirk on his face which i
found immediately intriguing after the
war and especially after the time skip
however i was surprised to see that he
seemingly had completely lost this
chaotic side of him and now felt a lot
more serious always thinking things
through and worrying about things that
might go wrong finally after dethroning
doflamingo it was really heartwarming
for me to see him grow closer and closer
with the straw hats slowly dropping his
serious intense manner and fully
subscribing to luffy's way of handling
things
now what at first glance seems to be an
inconsistency with his character turned
out to be one of the best character arcs
we've gotten in the story lost backstory
and his personal history with doflamingo
and corazon is one of my all-time
favorite flashbacks that i actually
dedicated a whole video to the flashback
is structured just like the backstories
of all the straw hats death tragedy and
something that luffy has to free them
from in the case of law that thing is
his obsession with doflamingo after
being saved and loved by corazon who
tells him about the will of thee law
believes that he must inherit his
savior's will to take down doflamingo
for the threat he poses to the world
[Music]
i think something that's quite easy to
overlook is that law believes that
corazon saved him only because he
revealed his middle name to him and as a
result he tries to pay this kindness
back by dedicating his whole life to
revenge this obsession is further fueled
because law blames himself for the death
of his loved ones he believes himself to
be a failure which might sound weird to
western fans who i think generally see
law as a pretty damn accomplished
character however what living in japan
has taught me is that this strong theme
of brothers in dressrosa is not by
accident we of course have this for
luffy and sabo who reunite over their
shared goal to retrieve ace's devil
fruit
but for law it's particularly important
see here in japan the relationship
between older and younger siblings is
somewhat sacred you should always
respect your older brother under any
circumstances but it's always his duty
to protect his younger siblings
which is for instance why ace's death
was so extremely meaningful law however
despite training to be a doctor is
unable to save his little sister and we
get this heartbreaking scene where he
has the exact same reaction as luffy
when she dies
[Applause]
similarly he can protect the other
orphans and i would even go so far as to
say that he blames himself for corazon's
death as well see it never occurred to
law nor to any japanese reader i assume
that doflamingo would do the unthinkable
thing and actually kill his younger
sibling and so in a sense law as an
older brother once again had to lose a
younger sibling he loved
i hope that this helps you realize why
dressrosa was even more important to
eastern fans than it already was and why
law is even more popular among fans
there
now of course law as a helpless and
traumatized boy is not to blame for any
of these but it didn't change the fact
that he always felt guilty about it in
lost mind taking down doflamingo and
fulfilling coruscant's mission was the
only way he could remedy himself from
this guild and so up until saba odi just
like luffy and the other supernova he's
mostly focusing on getting stronger and
so the law we meet at the auction house
is simply enjoying how much closer he's
gotten to dofi in terms of strength
after the war however things change law
realizes that the new era is coming now
and with it his chance to make a move so
he decides to save luffy the person we
saw punching a celestial dragon and
becoming the center of attention at
marineford because he sees someone else
who's capable of fulfilling corazon's
hopes for the d-clan and so after he
spends two years planning his move on
doflamingo he doesn't hesitate to team
up with luffy once they cross paths once
again on punk hazards completely by
accident by the way
[Laughter]
law very quickly understands though that
without luffy his plan would already
have failed right here on punk hazards
and more and more is taken in by luffy's
ability to master any situation no
matter how impossible it may seem and so
after being taken out by dophie and
having to leave the fight he was waiting
for his entire life to luffy he even
says that in the case that luffy should
lose and die he wanted to die next to
him
[Music]
at this point law fully trusts and
respects our captain and yet when luffy
finally defeats dophie after what feels
like 12
473 episodes when all citizens of
dressrosa are swept away by tears of joy
and relief this is the reaction we get
from law
now at first i thought that law simply
had to process what had happened but
this is pretty much the only reaction we
ever get from him even though his big
goal has finally been achieved he still
doesn't feel free and fulfilled the
weight on his shoulders is somehow still
there and i think it's this why so many
people are confused about lost character
arc the true resolution to his past
where he can finally embrace luffy's
deed and come back into the light is a
much smaller moment during the epilogue
of dressrosa but first break i quickly
want to introduce you to squarespace who
is the sponsor of today's video thank
yous
there's no second camera thank you
squarespace with squarespace you can
create your own personal website without
any prior knowledge by using the
wonderfully designed templates they
offer to build your very own that looks
and feels professional there are a ton
of options to choose from and endless
ways to customize everything so it fits
your personal needs perfectly if you
want to try it out for yourself for free
head over to squarespace.com and once
you're ready to launch your own website
use my link in the description below to
get 10 off your first purchase of a
website or domain now the moment i'm
talking about is this small interaction
law has with sengoku the former fleet
admiral who had been corazon supervisor
within the marines
now what both sengoku and i realized in
this moment is the fact that law has
always assumed that he had been saved
for being a d an enemy of the gods with
high expectations in him to fulfill his
role the beauty of this scene is how
sengoku breaks law's world view with one
sentence and frees him from his past
and so it's these two panels here that
actually mark the conclusion of law's
character arc and the end of his
suffering oda's subtle genius okay so
law's arc is over now right he has done
what he set out to do and even found
peace by embracing the unconditional
love that corazon had for him so why
exactly is law still there what is his
purpose in the story and what goal does
he have now three common theories i see
popping up a lot are that a law will
betray luffy and go for the one piece
itself b that law is actually a member
of the secret marine organization sword
or c that law will sacrifice himself to
perform the immortality surgery on luffy
here are my thoughts on these and why i
don't think it's gonna be either of the
three okay so law could betray luffy
based on the idea that pirate alliances
always end in betrayal but given the
fact that law was not only freed from
his burden by luffy but also was
prepared to die with him kinda tells me
that this doesn't make too much sense
the whole point of law's arc was to show
how kind he actually is at heart so as
long as oda doesn't pull another chondro
i'm gonna say with a lot of confidence
that this won't happen
now the sword thing on the other hand
could be true especially given that
corazon was a marine spy as well drake
for example has infiltrated kaido's crew
and if aokiji is also a member of the
group he has infiltrated blackbeard now
law has mostly been just traveling with
his own crew but i guess you could argue
that he technically infiltrated the
straw hats however to be honest i don't
quite see the point of it law is already
a fully fleshed out and interesting
character plus he's a devoted d who are
the enemies of the celestial dragons
but it's possible i guess now while i
think that law might very well die at
some point and use his ability on
someone else maybe i don't think it'll
be luffy here's why luffy's goal is to
find the one piece with his friends
otherwise it'll not be worth it i mean
in some way or form becoming pirate king
is only a tool for luffy a milestone to
fulfill a bigger dream that doesn't just
include himself so if were to sacrifice
himself for him even without luffy's
permission it would change his journey
remember luffy didn't want to hear
anything that raylee knew and he detests
people who use others as tools like how
big mom used her daughter for political
alliances so i can easily imagine a
scene where law tries to sacrifice
himself but luffy stops him similarly to
how he stopped sanji and robin from
sacrificing themselves for him as well
also remember that on thriller bark zoro
sanji and robin knew that luffy must
never know about zorro almost dying by
sacrificing himself so o'hara you might
say now what will law do then i
personally think that law now has a new
goal and will loyally fight side by side
with luffy till the very end and this
goal is to find the true meaning behind
the d-clan and the will of d he has been
obsessed with it his entire life and now
finally with luffy has found someone
that actually acts in exactly the way
corazon explained it to him he was there
after all both when luffy punched
charlos and when luffy punched
doflamingo and so i think that law is
simply interested in reaching love tale
not to become pirate king but to learn
the true history something we see him
discussing with robin and when you think
about it law actually has the most
unsuitable crew compared to most other
supernova to reach love tale he even
sent them away just before carrying out
his master plan against dophie his men
seem to be more a crew of doctors than
of fighters and i think that's what
their role is gonna be for the rest of
the story in other words now that law
doesn't feel obligated to be a good d
anymore he has freely chosen the goal to
become one by following the man he now
believes can actually become pirate king
[Music]
and now we get into the spicy stuff
because interestingly enough oda might
have already told us what lost role will
be based on his naming scheme law unites
a lot of references to british seafaring
as oda stated himself law was inspired
in part by the real-life 18th century
pirate edward lowe who was known for his
cruelty like cutting off enemy body
parts he had a deprived childhood
surviving by stealing and was brought up
by a family of criminals sound familiar
so basically oda took this real-life
pirate and gave him a twist law is
rumored to be cruel but actually is not
plus he actually cuts up people but only
using his devil fruit ability there are
a lot more british influences though the
white city in the north blue where law
was born is most likely inspired by the
white city in london in northern europe
which is famous for hosting the japanese
british exhibition law literally sails
on a yellow submarine a homage to the
famous song by the beatles
however its last name itself that has
the most clues in japanese trafalgar's
actually spelled torah faruga with luffy
actually calling him torah
and torah literally means tiger keeping
law in line with the animal theme of the
warlords now the other two major clues
in his name are again trafalgar as well
as water because in japanese the
combination of the taboo name water
wataru and his given name law ro form
the word waterloo
now the battle of trafalgar and the
battle of waterloo are two of the most
famous battles in history bought in the
same war that led to the downfall of
emperor napoleon during the battle of
trafalgar of the coast of spain the
british were led to victory by the
strategy of naval hero horario nelson
who not only had lost an arm but was
also shot during the battle waterloo on
the other hand became famous as the
downfall of emperor napoleon in this
sense the battle of trafalgar and nelson
wounds would represent dress rosa which
is also inspired by spain waterloo then
would represent wano and the end of the
emperor in this case kaido which was
enabled by the previous battles now of
course law is one of these central
figures fighting in wano right now and
it will be interesting to see what will
happen to him after that battle is won
there has always been a strong theme of
death surrounding his character the
surgeon of death his devil fruit ability
the death number four in japanese with
his four names and his bounty of 440
million there's a ton so law might
actually very well die but i would
personally prefer it to see him become
the happy and free person that corazon
originally wanted him to become and
actually you can watch his analysis by
clicking right here thanks for watching